Thôi, tình rồi tên và Fox News từ hướng về hướng thiệu theo lắm,
đã phải viên của tổng thống như đoàn tràm về vấn đề uống khai nè.
Đãn đe yêu ý tưởng, vời vệt tình thành một lý mình phòng thủ mới thay thí na tổ.
Ông cho rằng nó tổ đăng cho thấy những hạnh chế trong khả năng hành động.
Ông theo lắm của đề cập đến khả năng sử dụng một mặt lưới miên bóng của một tụi cua xe như là Nhật Bản,
O sử lia, nước, bà làm và cả uống khai nè.
Theo ông những cua xe này của thị đọng phải chào cho một câu chút phòng thủ mới,
và trường một cạnh tổng thủ mới đoàn trăm ngờ lần trị trinh nè.
Cho rằng tất cả đồng mình trư chiêu xảy đầy đủ chính giọt đặc biệt chút cuộc sương lột mời i ran.
Qua trường nguyên bà không biểu cũng mạnh, về suy rằng và trọng của người tổng đoàn đình trộ ổ và anh mình tần cầu.
Theo bui đình về hướng nè, tổng, về suy phỏ lý mình cạnh có khu chiến khắp lý và sử phay trận của cô hội nguy,
các cái kiến trái trường cho thấy trường lợp biệt tương hai của các lý mình anh mình truyền thống,
bận đăng tích giản cho mất cả những môi trường đẹp chính trị văn cầu có nhiều biệt đậu.